Hello world,
it's Saroj and let's make our own
language translator using tensorflow.
Today there are about 6,800 different
languages spoken across the world and in
an increasingly globalized world,
nearly every culture has interactions
with every other culture in some way.
That means there are an incalculable
number of translation requirements every
second of every day across the world.
Translating is no easy task.
A language isn't just a collection of
words and if rules of grammar and syntax,
it's also a vast interconnected system
of cultural references and connotations.
And this reflects a centuries old problem
of two cultures wanting to communicate
but are blocked by the language barrier.
Our translation systems
are fast improving though.
So whether it be an idea or story or
request each new advanced means one less
message will be lost in translation.
During the Second World War,
the British government was hard at
work trying to decrypt the Morse code.
Did radio communications that Nazi Germany
used to send messages securely known
as enigma. They decided to hire a man
named Alan Turing to help in their effort.
And when the American government
learned of their translation effort,
they were inspired to try it themselves
postwar specifically because they needed
a way to keep up with Russian
scientific publications.
The first public demo of a machine
translation system translated 250 words
between Russian and English in 1954 it
was dictionary based so it would attempt
to match the sorts language to
the target language word for word.
The results were poor since it
didn't capture syntactic structure.
The second generation of
systems used intro lingua.
That means they changed a source language
to a special intermediary language
with specific rules and coded into it.
Then from that generated
the target language. This
proved to be more efficient,
but this approach was soon over shadowed
by the rise of statistical translation
in the early nineties primarily from
engineers at IBM innovation at IBM.
A popular approach was to break the source
texts down into segments and compare
them to an aligned bilingual corpus using
statistical evidence and probabilities
to choose the most likely translation.
Nowadays,
the most used statistical translation
system in the world is Google translate
and with good reason.
Google uses deep learning to translate
from a given language to another with
state of the art results.
So how do they do this?
Let's recreate their results in tensorflow
at to find out the data set we'll be
using to train our language translation
model is a corpus of transcribed the Ted
talks. It's got both the English
virgin and the French version,
and our goal will be to create a model
that can translate from one to the other.
After training,
we'll be using TensorFlow's built in data
utiles class to help us preprocess our
dataset and we'll start by
defining our vocab size,
which is the number of words we
want to train on from our dataset.
We'll send it to 40 k for each,
which is a small portion of the data.
Then we'll use the data utilized class
to read the data from the data directory,
giving it our desired vocab size and it
will return the formatted and tokenized
words in both languages.
Well then initialize
tensorflow placeholders for
our encounter in Dakota inputs.
Both will be integer tensors
that represent discrete values.
They will be embedded into a
dense representation later.
We'll feed our vocabulary words to the
encoder and the Incode had representation
that's learned to the decoder.
Now we can build our model.
Google published a paper more recently
discussing a system they integrated into
their translation service called
neural machine translation.
It's an encoder decoder model inspired
by similar work from other papers on
topics like tech summarization.
So whereas before Google translate,
we translate from language
a to English to language B.
With this new NMT architecture,
it can translate directly from
one language to the other.
It doesn't memorize phrase
to phrase translations.
Instead it encodes the
semantics of the sentence.
This encoding is generalized so it can
even translate between a language pair
like Japanese and Korean that it
hasn't explicitly seen before.
So I guess we can use an LSTM recurrent
network to encode a sentence in language
a. The RNN spits out a hidden
state s which represents
the vectorized contents of
the sentence.
We can then feed as to the decoder,
which will generate the
translated sentence in language.
B Word by word sounds
easy enough, right? Wrong.
There's a drawback to this architecture.
It has limited memory.
That hidden state pass of the LSTM is
where we're trying to cram the whole
sentence.
We want to translate.
S is usually only a few hundred
floating point numbers long.
The more we try to force our sentence
into this fixed dimentionality vector,
the more lossy our neural
net is forced to be.
We could increase the hidden
side of the Lstm after all,
they are supposed to remember
longterm dependencies,
but what happens is as we increase
the hidden size h of the Lstm,
the training time increases exponentially.
So to solve this,
we're going to bring
attention into the mix.
If I was translating a long sentence,
I probably glanced back at the source
sentence a couple times to make sure I was
capturing all the details.
I iteratively pay attention to the
relevant parts of the source sentence.
We can let neural nets do the same by
letting them store and refer to previous
outputs of the LSTM.
This increases the storage of our model
without changing the functionality of
the LSTM.
So the idea is once we have LSTM
outputs from the encoder stored,
we can query each output
asking how relevant they are
to the current computation
happening in the decoder. Each
encoder output gets a relevancy score,
which we can convert to a probability
score by applying a softmax activation to
it.
Then we extract a context vector,
which is a weighted summation
to the Incode outputs.
Depending on how relevant they
are. Memory enough, pay attention.
You have to buddy up spam.
He sneaks past health,
ammonia know as soupy center president
cell memory. Enough pay attention.
We'll build our model using tensorflow
is built in embedding attention sequence
to sequence function,
giving it our encoder and decoder inputs
as well as a few hyper parameters.
We define like the number of layers.
It builds a model that is just
like the one we discussed.
Tensorflow has several built in models
like this that we can drop into our code
easily.
So normally this alone would be fine and
we could run this and the results will
be decent,
but they added another improvement to
their model that requires more code,
a hundred gps and a week of training.
Seriously, that's what it took.
We won't implement it all
programmatically, but let's
dive into it. Conceptually,
if the outputs don't
have sufficient context,
then they won't be able
to give a good answer.
We need to include info about
future words so that the encoder,
how put is determined by
words on the left and right.
We humans would definitely use this
kind of full context to determine the
meaning of a word we see in a sentence.
The way they did this is to use a
bi-directional encoders, so it's two rns,
one that goes forward over the
sentence and the other goes backwards.
So for each word it
concatenates the vector outputs,
which produces a vector with context
from both sides and they added a lot of
layers to their model. The encoder
has one bi-directional RNN layer,
then seven unidirectional corn.
And layers.
The Decoder has eight unit directional
RNN layers. The more layers,
the longer the training time, so that's
why we use a single by directional layer.
If all the layers were by directional,
the whole layer would have
to finish before later.
Dependencies could start computing,
but by using unidirectional layers,
the computations can be more parallel.
We'll initialize our tensor flow
session then our model inside of it.
Let's see some results
after training first,
I'll give it this phrase looks
good, and now another phrase, nope.
While it's not perfect and
we still have a ways to go,
we're definitely getting closer to
having a universal translation model,
breaking it down and coder decoder
architectures offer state of the art
performance in machine translation.
By soaring the previous
outputs of LSTM cells,
we can judge the relevancy of each to
decide which to use via an attention
mechanism and by using
a bi-directional RNN.
The context of both past and future words
is used to create an accurate encoder
output vector. The coding challenge
winner from last week is Ryan Lee.
This was very impressive.
He created a recipe summarizer by
scraping 125,000 recipes from the web and
documented it all beautifully
with installation steps
so you can reproduce the
results yourself wizard of the week.
And the runner up is Sarah Collins.
Her Code Converts Scientific Papers to
texts and prioritizes them by topic.
This week's coding challenge is to create
a simple translation system using an
encoder decoder model.
All the details are in the read me
poster gambling in the comments,
and I'll announce a winner next week.
Please subscribe for more programming
videos, check out this related video,
and for now I've got to get a better GPU,
so thanks for watching.